you know we are out in front of big
headline making news right now only we
were backstage at the BT Awards for all
the reaction from the all-star print
tributes Jesse Williams game-changing
speech and a show-stopping opening
number by Beyonce tonight's top story
the best of the Beatty Awards
Yonsei was the surprise show opener and
it was spectacular
she danced barefoot in a fiery
performance of freedom and we joined by
Kendrick Lamar
she won four awards but had her mother
accept them she had to run straight from
the stage and get on a plane and fly to
London for our concert you're gonna take
all those awards and head over to London
or you're gonna take him home
yes I'm gonna take him and keep him for
how incredibly proud of you of your
daughter and how she continues to change
the game and set the mark oh I couldn't
be more proud of her not only a person
entertaining as she keeps evolving and
growing but as a person as promised
tonight also featured several epic
fringe tributes
including Jennifer Hudson and his former
love and collaborator Sheila E
how was this for you tonight very
emotional if we we put that together in
about two and a half days you know it
was also therapeutic for all of us to be
together
66 day
Maxwell's performance drew a comparison
to Madonna's at the Billboard Awards
he's doing the same song that we saw on
another award show that was done not
quite as well shall we say and he
absolutely slays it and co-host Anthony
Anderson rocked this Prince inspired
outfit I had the custom designed to go
get me these a little booty bump drawers
for men just yeah yes sir yeah yeah for
those who are lacking such as myself it
pumps him up a little bit Anthony
brought the laughs but it was actor
Jesse Williams who provided the moment
of the night and inspiration there has
been no war that we have not fought and
died on the front lines of there has
been no job we haven't done Jesse
Williams put it down save it with me
yeah was a gangster he laid down the
gauntlet
the Grey's Anatomy star was presented
with the Humanitarian Award and his
powerful speech had the crowd on its
feet we're done watching and waiting
while this invention called whiteness
uses and abuses us while extracting our
culture our dollars our entertainment
like oil black gold the great night for
messages for Pope firebrand and it's
like that was like that was a 60 speech
his speech to me was probably the
greatest speech I've ever heard on the
bTW stage I don't know if I've ever been
more proud of anyone in my life why do
you feel like it's important to speak
out you know I'm here for all of the
incredible activists attorneys
organizers singer Justin Timberlake was
watching the broadcast and was also
moved by Jesse speech but it backfired
for him on Twitter justin tweeted Jesse
Williams though hashtag inspired that
tweet prompted one follower to write so
does this mean you're going to stop
appropriating our music and culture
Timberlake replied oh you sweet soul the
more you realize that we are the same
the more we can have a conversation by
the thing is that just because we're
magic doesn't mean we're not real